how many records
did you cut with Dre for the detox [ __ ]
um because wasn't one of the only
records we got weren't you on yeah
actually the let the last two records
that he was putting out for the detoxing
records that I produced or a rodon yeah
I mean and I don't think we're ever
going to hear the quote-unquote detox
but like I was lucky I was blessed yeah
we heard your [ __ ] two records that I've
you know been released one of them was
the um
um uh I'm so bad with titles it was me
and Snoop and Dre I remember that one I
forget the name of it too wait a minute
let me put it yeah yeah kush yeah it was
kush and then the second one was
um Kush was hard what was the other ones
that one was just Dre and Snoop and I
was on the chorus as well on that one I
don't remember the other one I remember
Kush is the one I was thinking of yeah
Kush was a monster that [ __ ] was hard
yeah and it could have like to me Kush
was the type of record because he did
that one and then he tried to put out
the I Need a Doctor record and I was
like oh we're getting singles this
should equal in albums right it just
never happened yeah Dre is just such a
you know perfectionist
I think he's too perfect for himself I
think and it was a lot of fear involved
as to
not being number one as well too like if
he puts the album out and it's not
number one right I think I think they
had a lot to do and again I'm not
speaking for him and I could be
completely wrong yeah but from the
outside looking in it felt like he he
put too much on himself to succeed and
be successful when I thought check
yourself out yeah I believe personally
that he don't need it like he has
nothing to prove to anybody to me he's
the greatest producer out of the West
Coast and influencer when it comes to
hip-hop and gangster music yeah that no
matter what he would have dropped
everybody would have thirsted up they'd
have took it in I think when you have
the first two chronics being as perfect
as they were right but that's what I'm
saying like it's like Michael Jackson
trying to outdo Thriller right some
projects are meant to just Embrace a
group of people a certain way and some
it may not be statistically number one
for what he may see it but it may be a
body of work that may incorporate or you
can say um uh uh impact a certain types
or certain of people that might change
the world yeah so every record may do
something totally different I don't
change the course of Music think or
change the course of Life yeah right so
when you look at Bob Marley and his
music for instance his music changed
wars in Africa and in the Caribbeans and
also also I was gonna say later on but
those records were number one on the
charts no no but they made they meant a
lot yeah right and I think Dre has he
has to see it from that standpoint too
his records could have changed the
mindset of gangsters yeah especially
this generation because this
generation's [ __ ] up it's generous as
[ __ ] but Dre was actually kicking a
little bit of knowledge in the midst of
all of that like you can actually get
some perspective and I think when he
stopped it kind of changed the course of
the direction of where the future
gangsters were going that's fair yeah
it's rough right now with just all the
violence and yeah it's crazy it's deep